let's talk about early voting we have
seen over 7 million Americans already
vote nearly 5 million of those seven
million votes in what are called loosely
battleground states and this includes a
representative sample of absentee
ballots as well as early voting now I'm
going to be voting early tomorrow Friday
here in Massachusetts I was going to
wait until november eighth the sort of
be part of the of the whole scene but i
had a 15 minute wait to vote in the
primary uh and i can only imagine that
the lines are going to be even longer to
vote on november eighth and I've got to
be here to do the show no time to waste
so I will be voting early so what do we
know so far about early voting well the
analysis is that in some states
Democrats have improved their position
relative to now in 2012 early voting and
Republicans also have some good news so
the early voting numbers look good for
Democrats in North Carolina in Nevada
and in Arizona Republicans seem to have
some good news out of Iowa and that is a
state that Donald Trump conceivably
could win this election Florida is a
really interesting one because both
candidates are sort of claiming that
Florida is good for them and it's really
the issue because number one Florida is
the state most likely to swing the
election no one state is more than fifty
percent likely to swing the election but
if you look at nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com florida is the state
with the highest chance of swinging the
election i think something like 15 or 17
percent so the Trump campaign is saying
Oh early voting is helping us in Florida
it's true that there are more
Republicans than Democrats that have
done early voting in Florida but here's
the confusion the Republican early
voting in Florida their lead is far
smaller than it was in 2012 so
Republicans are saying hey if you look
at raw early voting totals in Florida
more Republicans have voted than
democrats democrats are looking at
florida and saying in early voting at
this point in 2012 we were way down to
republicans and this time were barely
down to republican so it's really a
matter of how you want to look at the
numbers and ipad and finding the
democratic argument here far more
compelling which is last year obama won
florida and you were down big two
Republicans at this point in early
voting and now you're barely down to
republicans that to me seems like an
improvement for Democrats yeah i think
all signs at this point point to a trump
landslide loss and I I mean II at this
point you have to win all the swing
states and pick off something like
Pennsylvania right or New Hampshire
Colorado State's worries down like ten
percent and it's been increasingly
suggested including by Senator Rand Paul
who was one of the 17 original
Republican candidates for president this
year that the polls showing Hillary
ahead are designed to suppress turn out
he was on a program called the Tom
Wroten morning show on 800 w vh you West
Virginia I don't understand how this
argument makes sense let's listen to it
and see if we can figure it out but but
what about the the national polls that
have Hillary way out in front here we
are less than two weeks before the
election can Donald Trump pull this off
you know I think sometimes polling is
done to dampen election turnout so when
Trump says the things rigged I'm not
sure exactly what he means I'm not sure
I would agree with him but I do think
that when we say over and over someone
can't win that is a form of rigging in
the sense that it it is it is designed
to suppress turnout this is genuine BS
from Rand Paul you're talking about
multiple overlapping levels of nonsense
first of all is the idea that if you
think your candidate is losing you're
less likely to vote that may be true but
it could be argued that if you think
your candidate is down you'll actually
go vote right i mean pat i think that
you could you could make the case that
if you really don't want Hillary Clinton
to win and you keep hearing that Hillary
is winning maybe you would stay home if
you think Trump has no shot but maybe
you would be more inspired and motivated
to go out and vote yet jumps doing no
favors to himself he's only suppressing
his own vote and we know that Rand Paul
2 is up for re-election for his Senate
seat there is the concern on the Clinton
side that if people think she's well
ahead they won't vote thinking she
doesn't need their votes so that's also
an angle which is it's a really risky
strategy for Hillary Clinton to say oh
let's rig the polls how she would do it
I don't know let's rig the polls to make
it seem like we're winning because that
also Pat could make it so that Hillary
supporters say oh even though she's
really only up by one the polls have
been rigged to say she's up ten she
doesn't need my vote anymore i think
that rand paul's allegation here make no
sense because it's to Hillary Clinton's
detriment to do this yeah we know that
if they contest is close that drives up
voter turnout because if you look at
swing states over the years right others
like a ten percent higher turnout rate
for four states that are competitive
there's the polls themselves also which
are done by pollsters and number one
there's no evidence that pollsters are
skewing polls to show Hillary ahead
number two there's no really good reason
to think that pollsters would do that
and number three there's really no
realistic explanation as to why Hillary
Clinton would want that the best way as
Pat just pointed out to skew polls in
order to help someone would be if you're
ahead if you're Hillary Clinton and
you're really up eight you would want to
skew the polls to show that they're tied
because then people thinking she needs
my vote would not stay home so this
entire hypothesis from Rand Paul really
doesn't pass the smell test it smells
like BS and it absolutely is